on my porn game I'd be able to show you
some good porn because back in the day I
had a little porn addiction Jada Pinkett
Smith's getting candid about her past
struggle with porn I actually feel like
I was using maybe addiction a little
lightly and maybe I will say now that I
had a unhealthy relationship to porn at
one point in my life where I was trying
to practice exactly the confession went
down on the latest episode of her
Facebook watch show red Tabletalk Jada
explained to her co-hosts who also
happened to be her mom Adrienne and her
daughter willow that she was single when
she turned to pornography I wasn't in a
relationship when I had a porn addiction
but thank goodness I got to give it to
Jada she's being so open and honest and
I actually think it's pretty great to
see this kind of authenticity nowadays
but when willow asked her what prompted
her addiction she explained that it came
from an emotional place it was actually
like filling like an emptiness at least
you think it is but it's actually not
the women also discussed the stigma
around porn and how it can affect a
person's life actually reading like some
of the effects of pornography like the
idea that it really gives you false
expectations as far as sexual
interaction yeah I can definitely see I
commend that a woman should always be
willing and ready it is never a no you
know so I can definitely see how that
kid creates
write a unrealistic expectation
okay so porn may not be a typical topic
of conversation for a grandma mom and
daughter
but when et caught up with the three
ladies last week they said almost no
topic is off the table this one's about
porn ah
I mean do you have those those that you
like I don't know if I can talk about
this and is there a topic that you say
we're never going to touch I think I
hate I don't know if there's a topic
that we would say we
never going to touch we've kind of
decided that we wanted to kind of stay
away from politics and religion
yeah goes to speak a lot to spirituality
so in a lot of ways that is different
the women also say that because they are
so open and honest their guests feel
like they can be too what's that magic
sauce and just makes people say yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna spill it well
I guess I think it's not even so much
because I've never our intention to say
you know we just always want to have
just real proper citations and so I
think it's we're in the conversation
with you right yeah yeah we're we're
we're sharing our stories we're sharing
our experiences and it's just about
community you know we're just communing
and I think when you see someone else
being vulnerable it makes you feel like
you can be vulnerable so when you know
most people be super nervous and you
know that's kind of a thing when they
come but when it's always yeah exactly
it's always when they see us be
vulnerable then they're like oh okay
it's it's okay to be going on it's a
safe space for going oh really I love
these three women and I truly enjoy
listening to their conversations they
are so fearless I know that I would
never have talked porn with my grandma
like no way Jose but of course will be
here to fill you in on all the big red
table talks to come so make sure that
you subscribe to all things et until
next time I'm Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]